um this episode was insane and we have
so much to discuss that I didn't even
have the energy for witty intro so let's
just do this welcome River babes
I'm your host Liana Galera and this is
your Sweetwater secrets after-show for
episode 319 chapter 54 fear the reaper
and this was actually a big big big
episode filled with tons of twists and
turns that I actually loved strong words
from a local hero we're gonna dive right
in and get started with the blue and
gold breakdown first up Archie found
himself in the middle of a sticky and
bloody situation remember the guy that
was all hopped up on G that he had to
fight in last week's episode he died you
killed him in that ring you know it
sheesh can't Archie catch a break even a
sweet but brief father-son scene with
Fred couldn't make him feel better
you're not dead
but by the end of the hour and one solid
slap later did you get that Archie did
everything he could to make sure that
Randy's family got the money they needed
to get by and as for goodbyes well we'll
get to the whole josie storyline in just
a little bit meanwhile it's time to
focus on the quest for princess
jellybeans during a brutal confrontation
current revealed to the jones family
that her fate is linked to one last
round of Griffin's and gargoyles I
accept the invite to play let's see if
you can bring jellybeans home over the
course of the game Gladys needed to
revealed SP that she's the new drug
queen of Riverdale our three Joneses
were forced to rob pops at gunpoint and
we even had the return of the totally
not dead and now one-eyed penny Peabody
this how the mummy told you one weird
and slightly sensational sword fight
later GLaDOS defeated penny again and
then it was up to Jughead to finish the
game too bad he was betrayed and then
locked in a refrigerator instead
he eventually got out saw the gargoyle
King ran like hell reunited with
jellybean and then the jones family said
goodbye to Gladys you take good care of
my babies and as for my now favorite
twist in Riverdale history and the best
storyline of the night well wedding
bells are ringing at the farm and Tony
revealed edgers true intentions to Betty
after the big wedding
Edgar's planning to a job juniper and I
quit that makes no sense
if you're trying to get the twins why
not just marry Paulie
you can't just adopt random babies what
is this about
so Betty amped up her investigative
skills and started sleuthing through
Evelyn's school files and she discovered
a sensational secret that even I didn't
see coming I'm not even mad that's
amazing turns out Evelyn has been lying
this whole time she's been pretending to
be a 17 year old junior in high school
for over a decade and I think that's
frickin hilarious yeah when she wasn't
trying to convince Hiram Lodge to move
her murderous father into a room with a
view at that fancy new prison Betty was
enlisting the help of her Auntie blossom
to save the twins we get the boy but
Edgar keeps the girls those were the
only terms that they would accept side
note can someone please explain to me
how these babies are still babies are
they not aging did the floating keep
them young forever should we be
concerned probably this is not but if
you're already thinking what the farm is
happening here just wait it gets even
better and by better I mean weirder
Evelyn is Edgar have and Evers wife not
daughter I love it the fact that 26
year-old Evelyn was calling her husband
her dad you knew my dad was like is so
effed up in the worst and best way
possible and what makes it even more
bizarre the fact that the entire farm is
totally cool with this you can't marry
Edgar he's already married
Tamlyn you think I don't know that yeah
now after escaping the farm's clutches
Betty returned home to the Pennbrook so
that's where she's been staying and
Veronica delivered some shocking news
about her father's transfer to Hiram's
fancy prison there was some kind of
accident did he escape no there were no
survivors oh my goodness the hits just
kept on coming in 3:19 and since this
next storyline ended a relationship
let's chuck it all out in seven seconds
in heaven
Josie McCoy aka the most talented and
level-headed person in Riverdale at this
point has been realizing that Riverdale
is maybe not the best town to be in if
you have big-time dreams and oh I don't
know maybe don't want to risk getting
shot every other day in your favorite
diner now do you see why I need to get
the hell out of this town so she put on
another truly sensational performance at
la bonne nuit to convince her dad that
her big-time voice is better than this
small-town stage
her dad agreed to let her come on tour
with him and while Josie was thrilled
with this opportunity she needed to
sever all remaining ties in Riverdale
including her romantic link to Archie
could she have loved our time together
we're not in game and that's okay and
with one last kiss Archie said goodbye
to Josie as we all said farewell to the
short but sweet relationship of our
chose II oh but then in true Archie
fashion he gave some flirty eyes to
Veronica in the very next scene because
well that's just Archie and Riverdale
really wants us to remember that barchi
is nkv am I screwed with me in your
corner never and now let's switch over
to a round of hisses and kisses
first up hisses - hiram we're
essentially dissolving his truce with
Archie behind his back and conspiring
with Elio once again get a hobby
Hiram you're like a broken record that I
really want to throw away we'll see
about that
hisses - Tony for letting the farm
brainwash her - I thought you were
stronger than this babe - Penelope for
thinking hey I got one baby score we're
good and - the entire farm for being
totally cool about the fact that Edgar
and Evelyn have been pulling this
con-artist father/daughter routine over
and over and over again
join us and I'm sending hisses - Josie
for leaving us why am I not surprised
okay I tried and I failed I can't
actually be mad at Josie for wanting to
chase her dreams and get out of this
crazy evil snow globe of a town that
Riverdale has turned into over these
three seasons 100% switching over into
kisses I'm sending kisses to Josie and
actress Ashley Marie for doing an
amazing job with the outrageously small
storylines they've given her over these
past three years I adore you girl your
voice is angelic and we all wish you the
best of luck in New York with Katy keen
too cute for words and while we're on
the subject of goodbyes I'm sending
another massive kiss to Luke Perry's
final appearance on Riverdale well I
wish that his last scene with Archie had
been much longer I think we can all
agree that Fred Andrews was the only
loving kind and genuinely pure parent in
Riverdale while we're still not sure how
Fred's absence will be explained on the
show Luke Perry will be greatly missed
in Riverdale we'll never be the same
I don't know how to do this it's gonna
take you a minute to pick up the pieces
if you could give your younger self any
advice would you know you got to learn
it all on your own I really do believe
that you know life is experiential you
got to get out there and you got to try
it and you got to fail sometimes and to
get to any success you got to fail a few
times and so ya think you gotta earn it
how was your agent my father passed away
I never got to say this isn't goodbye
then dude damn right it's not
and now we're done thank you all so much
for tuning in and I'll see you next week
for our live Sweetwater preview of
episode 320 captor 55 prom night but
first please give this video a like and
then hit subscribe and then type fast
and furiously into the comments section
to tell me your kisses and kisses of
episode 319 were you shocked by the fact
that Evelyn is actually 26 and married
to Edgar what has been your favorite
Josie moment in Riverdale and what are
you gonna miss most about seeing Luke
Perry on our screens tell me everything
and I'll see you soon river babes
[Applause]
you
[Music]